Daniel Jeremiah he of NFL Network Fame
you have a podcast now as well do have a
podcast move the sticks podcast you move
the sticks podcast as well that you
could find on nfl.com an NFL network and
where else I feel now on itunes done if
you can find it all over the place and
Tom telesco charger GM will be here
correct this wheezy he's in this week
Tom to let's go and Brian Billick joined
the show this week as well to see a
Daniel Jeremiah by the way I'm good to
see you man I like this casual version
kind of socks are you wearing with this
outfit by the way showing the socks
before we introduce the other jamokes on
the show as they were told okay I
figured your via this purple socks match
the purple shirt there you go herbal
sucks it's all about the Saudis days
anyway uh yeah how do we get on that
pilot just had a muscle doing that um
true story so the other people on the
show today I said jamokes cuz when we
did the bacons own thing before we use
the word jamokes sitting over there
Chris Brockman has socks Chris law I
can't see shadow socks something I got
the low-cut all-star socks okay Brock
when I own those socks dude nice funky
weary you own them as in there there
cause wearing your soccer they're out
there nearly called fun socks sounds
like a pro I'm not borrowing a DJ
service separate member sock was the
same name come because stuff sometimes
at NFL network as Daniel can attest that
I disappear yeah that does happen but
look early you are right thank you are
we have one big dresser room at NFL
network and it looks just like a
football locker room okay and sometimes
this has happened before and I'm what a
preface is I'm not calling anyone a
thief but i have on around the NFL
looked at the large video wall and said
hey let's go live to kansas city where
re wolf is there with the chiefs and re
is uh wearing my tie is that that's
that's my tie and last year actually at
the Super Bowl we're on the field
MetLife Stadium about an hour and a half
before kickoff and I go over to talk to
ian rapoport NFL media insider ian
rapoport and I'm walking over there and
IANS about my height by the way right
and I walk over there it's jay glazer
yours truly Ian Rapoport Adam Schefter
Gregg Rosenthal we're all the exact same
height okay there's this like you must
not be this tall to report on the NFL so
I walk over to rapaport that's a great
look and tie and then I turn it around
yeah I got a little handsy I turned it
around all right that's actually my time
I don't know somebody gave it to me I'm
not I'm not accusing of taking my tie
but it is my time but it is my time
anyway I digress Ted is also here
they'll Teufel is also here the entire
crew is here and rich will be back on
Monday fear not rich back on Monday for
the rich eisen show if you'd like to
call in rich will be calling in for the
final segment of this show but you can't
as well 844 20 for rich 8 4 4 204 rich
is the phone number the twitter is at
Rich Eisen show my twitter is at andrew
siciliano his twitter also is move the
sticks you got it okay and don't make a
sound like you don't know oh no it's
words I follow you but it's likely
forget people's [ __ ] like you put your
number in the phone yeah you just don't
actually know what it is you just know
the name no she's coming up on monday
show sapper warren sapp dan Patrick and
dr. drew I have used that name before
I'll be honest but the real dr. drew
will be here you watch the game last
night yeah I was it was a very
interesting game look like it's gonna be
kind of one of those runaway Thursday
games and then all sudden we found
ourselves in a ballgame Houston JJ Watt
put on a show in defeat I can you
remember a player and defeat getting
more attention than JJ Watt because the
guys amazed can we roll the highlight
roll to highlight here because this game
last night was it was a Thursday game we
had all wanted to see ya but we had not
seen it through the first five week of
Thursday five weeks rather of Thursday
games we we wanted the close game we
wanted the game where we could watch in
the second half and say you know call
the friends and neighbors under this
game this game is actually happening and
there's something going on here but we
didn't think that right out of the gate
when Indianapolis gets out to the twenty
four to nothing lead you know the the
snarks on Twitter started a you know
blowing up at everyone else let's be
fair it's not Daniel just the people on
Twitter I think all of us were sitting
there saying here we go again t/y Hilton
here he goes again he had 223 receiving
yards
someone tweeted at me does Jonathan
Joseph have tea why hilton on his
fantasy team no that's a pretty bad
accusation twenty four to nothing Colts
got out please that catch by andre
johnson was insane knows his first
touchdown of memory serves in seven
weeks eventually houston makes this a
game Arian Foster is just amazing he's
beautiful to what is his gliding running
style it's just it's he's just one of
those guys you enjoy watching him on a
7-yard run because it's so effortless
and fluid and luck brought him back luck
TTYL hilton their brought him back that
is once houston made a game of it that
made it 33 to 21 then your guy JJ wow
this is a play everybody will spend the
whole day talking about is JJ watt he
kind of used his foot to kind of scoop
it to himself and then picks it up and
goes in and third touchdown of the year
but he's kind of talking about more
touchdowns in Calvin Johnson LeSean
McCoy so I was looking up some numbers
and the one that kind of was weird to me
not just JJ what hello d nadas got as
many pics as a seattle seahawks right
now and come on really bizarre is that
so you can you can get interesting he's
got to yeah and the seahawks only have
two but JJ watt for a team that didn't
win a lot of attention when his ways the
best defensive player in football was
obvious last night but Andrew Luck four
out of six games he's gone three hundred
seventy plus passing yards and and it's
not just him I mean you keep here and
it's just andrew luck and he puts
everybody on his back you start looking
at t y hilton and now we're seeing with
to wit what Dwayne Allen can bring to
the table the offensive line even minus
some guys did a nice job of my Bradshaw
getting more involved and their defense
has been outstanding i think this team's
got staying power well I guess that's
the question because it again Daniel
Jeremiah here NFL Network our Scout you
seem on total access he has a podcast as
well to move the six podcast you were in
the front office for the Ravens the
Browns and the Eagles during his NFL
career and he played quarterback at app
state I don't think we have that video
but we don't have that it's coming
though efforting an effort in that video
that's the thing about the Colts is that
you know they have the quarterback and
you know they have that transformational
player that can make everyone else
better yeah what is the rest of the team
good they have parts but are those parts
good enough with that quarterback to be
a legitimate contender because they make
the playoffs but then we've yet to see
them really making
yeah they want a game last year they're
kind of taking those steps right make
the playoffs the first year the next
year with Andrew Luck you win a game in
the playoffs and I think he's continued
to see them grow last year they had so
many injuries going into the playoffs
and he's feeding the ball to griff
whalen at that point time reggie wayne
wasn't there Dwayne Allen wasn't there
now they've also added Hakeem Nicks this
year to go along with some of their
other weapons on defense Andrew the last
three games they've given up three third
down conversions total so I don't think
we give their defense enough credit
Chuck Pagano is a defensive minded guy
and even without Robert Mathis they're
playing great on that side of the ball
is andrew luck because we used to say
this about Tom Brady that Tom Brady and
now we debate whether or not we can
still say it but we used to say he's the
guy that makes everyone around him
better you can sign JJ Stokes off the
street on a Tuesday a grant to JJ Stokes
at talent but this was at the end of his
career nice reference right and Tom
Brady cuz I remember that one week can
go out and make JJ Stokes look like he's
still something or anyone else for that
matter just just one little example is
Andrew Luck that guy where yes he needs
the he has people around him but he is
so good that he raises everyone else's
level I think so I absolutely think he
is I think you look at what he had to
play with at the end of the year last
year had some rookie free-agent
receivers and they go in and win a
playoff game with those guys I think
everybody's level play comes up around
him and he's got a unique he's gotta get
a unique leadership style he's he's
almost more like a linebacker you know
some of these quarterbacks can be kind
of professore 'i'll he's not like that
at all he mentioned last night of the
post game show with rich and everyone
else that you know as a kid he lined up
as a defensive end yeah and that he
still because he was asked are you a
quarterback or a football player
something like that paraphrasing and he
said I'm a football player he said he
likes do I think his words were play
football and get dirty when he's not a
quarterback so he doesn't mind
occasionally getting hitting up not that
he wants to get hit but you don't see
that no he's that off he's different and
and i actually had Ryan Greeks on my
podcast last week and he brought up the
fact that once Andrew Luck gets a big
hit in the game once he takes a big hit
it kind of gets him going fires him up
and he gets competitive and he takes his
play to another levels that scare you as
a GM no because he's built to take it I
mean you stand next to him he's built
like a dang line back sure he
huge Cam Newton's built like a defensive
end but there comes a point I know he's
morning you're a big dude but you watch
Andrew when Andrew runs even this
competitive is you saw him slide the
other day probably could've got a couple
extra more yards he got down but he's
he's just built to take the punishment I
remember watching him in college they're
playing USC a turnover Charice right in
place for the charger scoops it up
Andrew Luck levels him it was a
beautiful form tackle Latin last week's
game he played great against the ravens
had one bonehead interception perfect
form tackle i mean he is he's that kind
of a competitive physical guy that I
think everyone else in the team draws
from that we don't have it here but did
you see by chance on inside the NFL or
when we ran it on the network as well
when he was wired last week again I
didn't know I did not sit he is and I
and I used this term affectionately
because it takes one to know one he's a
dork oh yeah nursery door holiday about
him and when you hear him on the field
that final drive he goes over he's
talking to Pagano talking to pep
hamilton it says all right all right can
we score who we scored yes then he goes
to the huddle and he says all right
here's the deal and marshall mentioned
this last night too and it showed
marshall that he's that leader he said
all right guys guys guys stay in bounds
ball security and you could score and he
goes thumbs up scoring's good scoring is
good this is andrew luck last week you
can score and then when ahmad bradshaw
eventually fumbled in the red zone he
walks off talking into his helmet no no
survive this survive this survive this
survive this to himself and then at the
end at the end thank God thank God thank
God thank God thank God yeah and it's a
different guy he's a totally totally
different guy no hey special he's gonna
be he's gonna be one of the all-time
greats when it's all said and done
alright let's talk about the rookie
quarterbacks here because if you had
told me the Johnny Manziel heading into
what is this now week six would be the
only quarterback that is not yet playing
you have Teddy Bridgewater playing yeah
Blake bortles playing you have Derek
Carr playing my missing anybody here
could be Logan Thomas you gotta Kalugin
tom is hypothetically plank he got in
last week for the Cardinals andrew
stanton knocked out against the broncos
i'm going to assume the answer right now
is Bridgewater the most effective but is
bortles the best long
of that group I'm going to stick with
what I had when they were coming out
Andrew and I had Teddy Bridgewater as
the top guy he's only had one start
bortles had more opportunity but in that
one start with Bridgewater you saw
everything they want to see that I want
to see at least you saw somebody that's
very efficient he's accurate he works
through his progressions quickly he even
saw him move around you see him running
here against the Saints saw him move
around more in the action he said this
year than even he did in college so he
adds that dimension to it the word I
would use to describe Teddy if you had
one word is poised and I think he has
that I think that's key to being
successful did was his pro day as bad as
everyone made it out to be I wasn't at
the proto I was at the network we were
covering it live so I was in studio but
I kept him as my top quarterback after
that pro day and I was on the phone with
the general manager a couple weeks after
his pro day and I said look everything I
saw from him on tape I can't just flush
that because of a bad pro day in his
response was I was there I was at the
pro day if you would have been there you
would have dropped him that's how bad it
was that bad that's right now he did
wear gloves in that protein didn't
remember gloves he was with guys he
hadn't been training with he was cold
he'd been training in Florida then he
goes to the pro day Louisville so
there's a lot of different reasons for
it but my whole thing was everything you
saw on tape is what we're seeing so far
all right so i mentioned Manziel before
he has yet to play or i mean at least
yet to really get in there he's caught a
nice past and count but is a nice touch
brian hoyer is playing well Brian horns
playing so well that there is no way
barring an injury we're borrowing a
total collapse which are both possible
that Manziel is gonna get on the field
anytime soon forget about the what do
you do with horror thing let's say you
keep them let's pretend that what do you
do with Manziel and if so do you have
any value out there would someone say
after watching me the preseason you know
what I still want the guy I don't think
that's what the plan would be I really
don't I think when you look at man's own
if you watched him in the preseason you
saw a lot of the stuff he needed to work
on footwork why's he was very raw coming
out of Texas am that's gonna be an
adjustment for my I think this is the
best thing for him and for the Browns
that Hoyer is playing really well
because now you can you can take your
time with Manziel let him debate let him
get better and work on his craft on the
practice field can you learn on the
practice field I think you can I mean
sometimes you got to be in game action
now talking about fundamentals of
footwork
that stuff gets better on the practice
field if he had to get in there right
now do you think he'd be ready I think
he'd be out to play a different style I
don't think they could do what they're
doing right now what they're doing Brian
Hoyer see the crazy thing is and I agree
with you on the style is that people say
well let him run let him do this he
doesn't have rg3 speed no we're not
talking about that kind of game breaking
athlete doesn't have Russell Wilson
speed does he know Russell Wilson is a
little bit it's a better athlete is also
a very physical player that's another
thing you worry about with Manziel can
he physically hold up right and and
people say well just just run
read-option in pistol now know that not
know yeah he's not physically he's not
gonna physically hold up if you try and
do that right but Daniel Jeremiah is
gonna physically hold up for uh for one
more chat here coming up want to get
your thoughts on the two quarterbacks we
are going to see if the rose bowl
saturday brent hudley marcus mariota
this is marcus mariota i say then yo yo
yo yo D Mariota her to both ways
actually I have it more potato Jeremiah
come on did your lines gonna pull it out
this week I'll show you that's a battle
of bad how about we have one loss any
Chad who cares it any chance Syracuse
upset sports state 0 I got a little bit
of a bone to pick with you though huh oh
so I sent out a tweet something that you
guys you've criticized me before yes all
time I set my alarm for like 40 1 yeah
but you said it's a double like you show
the car in my arms and because I don't
want to miss I don't know what happens
when the first one goes off that you
can't i don't know if i hit snooze
sometimes I don't know cuz its uses for
tagging I the matter buddy yeah but if
you tap on tweeting this yours right
well let's let them see this so I tweet
this out this is a flick sure you screen
grabbed your phone yes so this is me I
tuna I wonder if I'll ever get used to
this so vegas to he'll get all the
alarms show I then see some chatter that
I then get brought into by Brockman
tweeting simple because I responded we
can see this next one here right heel
you captured this oh no no that's the
end yeah this is the end actually if
there's yet so so Daniel and Brockman
went into a back-and-forth do we have
that one or no well Brockman's up late
no oh no that's my that's my tweet sure
who I wrote back to law and I was like
really why are you waking up at 401 in
the morning and then DJ wrote back what
I said was like you know come on you
called me an alarm freaker I said I said
he's an alarm clock liar in the round
closed because of their first album
black liar they're great I remember
whenever the free agent frenzy started
you excited me up their sores I was
getting I was getting so notice the one
you know it's the one alarm what alarm
well the reason why you guys have the
same job right you guys do the same
thing you work the same hours right so
they're like I gotta wake up at three
forty-five then Brockman's like one
o'clock little more DJ like what's up on
Twitter all right there's no way this
dude this to me up to sir oh my god why
are we up the waiting like laws already
awake you better go to bed that's just a
little look into the window huh no you
took a nap or something that day yeah
yeah mom Andrew siciliano this is daniel
jeremiah from NFL network you know what
we call you a scout you used to be a
scout i think that that's pigeonholing
him you use more than a scout i know
this that we are sitting in here today
for Rich Eisen on the Rich Eisen show on
directv with a lot of different couches
by the way we have many couches we have
many chairs this is a beautiful new
studio studio in which rich will return
on Monday with Warren Sapp dr. drew will
be in studio and dan Patrick will join
him in a very large television screen
over there also Rob Lowe on the phone on
Tuesday Eddie George in studio Tuesday
planning ahead planning it all right if
you're planning ahead to the weekend
however there's a lot of good college
football this weekend the one that I'm
looking forward to and maybe it could
have been bigger if Oregon hadn't lost
last Thursday and if UCLA hadn't lost
this past Saturday but the Oregon UCLA
game at the rose bowl specifically here
for a couple of quarterbacks don't have
to be careful we're not suggesting here
the Marcus Mariota or brett hundley i
almost said Todd Hundley not him Brett
Hundley not a left-handed hitting
catcher we're not suggesting that they
need to go to the NFL draft or should go
to the NFL Draft just playing the
hypothetical if they were to go to the
NFL Draft tell me about these two
quarterbacks as a scout and what you see
well they're both talented guys that
have some flaws and I think you saw that
last week with each of them
I don't think either guy is all that
comfortable working inside the pocket
resetting your feet going through your
read and being able to play from a
confined pocket you just don't see that
a lot with them a lot of one read stuff
get the ball out some of that's a
function of the offense that they're in
they're both great runners Mariota does
it with speed Hundley does it more with
power but you saw last week with Hundley
ten sacks he takes against Utah now some
of that's on the on the front on the
offensive line are not very good but he
has a bad habit kind of dropping his
eyes holding onto the ball I'm not
working through his progression so
that's something that he definitely
needs to work on a Mario to fumbled a
couple times that games got over 20
fumbles in his career now you know I was
about to say we never see Brent hudley
throw down the field yet here we see him
twice throwing down the field that had
been I don't want to say a knock but a
concern hadn't it been coming into this
season because whenever i see UCLA play
I see Hundley complete a high percentage
of passes movies team down the field but
nothing is more than ten yards beyond
the line of scrimmage now obviously
those two as we see the numbers on the
screen those two passes we just saw
there or an exception but is that a
concern well it's just part of the often
slit you run I mean it is what it is
when he's when it's his first read down
the field when he's hitting his back
step and throwing a Depot he throws a
pretty deep oh you saw it on the tape
right there the problem with him has
been when he's got to work through a
progression when they take things away
and now he's got to dial the ball
downfield you see some errant throws his
accuracy is not all that crisp so that's
something he needs to work on mario de
is intriguing just because you have the
size he has that rare speed kind of like
Colin Kaepernick in the speed department
he's got more touch than cat pad coming
out of Nevada but he doesn't have that
pure arm strength the Kaepernick and the
other thing I see and again this is just
judging from my on trained I whenever I
look up and I see Mariota and it's a
product of the Oregon offense these guys
are 50 yards wide open yeah that's the
hardest that's why he's such a tough
evaluation he's a unique evaluation
because you don't get the examples of
those tight window throws you watch the
michigan state game the first half a lot
of tight windows he's not very
successful trying to squeeze balls in
and and and they're not as good of an
offense second half they make
adjustments they scheme it up and he's
got guys catching touchdowns like punts
because they're so wide open that's what
makes his evaluation tricky so are
either of these guys
so I'm trying to put a grade on these
quarterbacks yet are telling them they
should come out in the NFL Draft but can
either of these guys do what's a Teddy
Bridgewater did two weeks ago come in
first year maybe not weak one but come
in first year and lead a team to 450
yards 500 yards of offense whatever was
for the Vikings are we know these guys
have talent but is that talent ready for
the NFL I think you would have to cater
your offense more towards them than you
would with Teddy Bridgewater I think
Teddy Bridgewater something you can fit
into a lot of different schemes I think
with those two guys you're going to kind
of have to adopt some of the stuff that
they do maybe some more design
quarterback runs getting the ball out
quick different things I think Teddy
Bridgewater's further along his
development at this point in time coming
out than the knees to are these guys
stars or they starters yeah that's yet
to be determined I mean I think they're
both you know potential to be starters i
would say mario de of the two has a star
potential if he can develop and get
there because of his feet why because
he's just such a special athlete he's a
special athlete he I think he's just got
a little more natural play to them than
Hundley does Hundley's a little bit
stiffen I'm not quite as high how I
guess there's a bigger picture question
here the the skill position guys from
Chip Kelly's Oregon offense as a scout
are you concerned with how they big
picture translate to the NFL well i
think you know you got to take those
things individually because there's
always those exceptions when you're
talking about those players the tough
thing is it's not just chip kelly in his
system it's college system as a whole
now people always ask you a lot of times
when you put your rankings out of
players before the draft but but this
guy has 1300 receiving yards this guy
has 17 touchdowns as a scout you almost
have to throw stats out the window in
college right now because it is so
offensive friendly in these systems it
doesn't necessarily mean anything when
you're trying to translate to the next
level I want to talk about Todd Gurley
if we could because for those who don't
know Todd Gurley has been suspended
indefinitely here by Georgia allegedly
the story is autographs money and
autographs and and and so be it here
Todd Gurley is one of those special
backs where when you watch him you say
wow I cannot wait to see him in the NFL
yet we're hesitant
these days to take running backs at the
top of the draft is he an exception I
think he'll be an exception whenever
whenever he decided to come out because
of his skill set he's one of those
unique guys people always ask for
comparisons Andrew when I watched him I
say okay see a little bit of Steven
Jackson I see a little bit of Marshawn
Lynch even when I was back with the
Ravens we saw Fred Taylor a lot i see
summer fred taylor in his style of play
and i think there is still a place in
the first round for those big time
runners we just haven't had those those
guys come alone we've had a lot of
undersized backs because of the spread
system in college he is a big physical
guy that's built to kind of be a
workhorse you know our colleagues at NFL
Network always like to say or a couple
of them do that if we had a marshall
faulk talent that talent would be still
at the top of the draft not suggesting
Todd Gurley's Marshall Faulk in any way
whatsoever but it isn't necessarily just
a product of today's offenses there
hasn't been that guy has there no it
just really hasn't been we've had some
nice players I mean we've looked at a
lot of second-round backs and that's the
one thing it's like all the positions
been devalued but all those second-round
backs is a lot of them have hit you look
at LeSean McCoy look what levy on bells
doing right now a lot of those guys have
I just think in terms of having
everything the size the power the speed
those guys don't come around very often
anymore none that at all hey what are
your thoughts if we could quickly here
on the college football playoff because
it struck me this week when I was
watching something and they started
throwing out names once again here's why
I think the four teams would be for the
college football playoff and they're all
sec team basically other than Florida
State it struck me that no one's going
to be happy with this thing we think
that people will be happy and this is a
better system than what we've had we all
agree on that but it at the end no one's
really going to be happy because the 15
the sixth team since any tournament yet
the 65th team forever was upset it's
what it is but it's not a 60-40 feeling
yeah it's a 14 field I like it I still
like it I'll take it I like this a lot
better than what we've had in the past
i'm not going to you won't catch me
complaining but i know a lot of people
see it want to see it go to eight and i
think that's where it'll eventually get
but right now i'm happy with for you
think we have three SEC teams no they're
all going to beat each other up there's
the SEC they're all in sec west they all
have to play each other I think that
will take care of itself but
but but don't we don't we still see I
still think that we're going to be
sitting here screaming about bias at the
end well we could be but I mean look we
see all these losses that teams have had
this last weekend we have five the top
teams I get that so you lose your excuse
to mela if you if you have a clean sheet
and you don't make it into the top four
you've got grounds to complain if you
drop a game and that's a you problem
what about a florida state by how many
does a show you serious Lord estate well
but how it is certain by how many does
Serge I will I will order still say
despite a an unbelievable effort from
Syracuse at Florida State squeaks by
with a margin of 26 27 26 or 27 now
that's taking into account the fact that
Syracuse fired its offensive coordinator
this week obviously I mean has a
question market quarterback that's why
that's why I've put him at 27 the game
is at the carrier dome otherwise it
could have been at home who could have
been at 21 or 22 but all that turmoil i
think Florida State stretches that from
21 or 22 26 28 and you do realize that
homecoming homecoming changes the
dynamic hold on cuz go ask you to cuz
you we have to syracuse crabs here how
many games did you guys attend in a
typically allow and dependency don't
over again you at all well every game I
want all the games that I wasn't doing
play-by-play for yes means play-by-play
I guess yeah that night I want here's my
question homecoming in college what's
the difference we know home like a
homecoming game and a regular game in
college I don't know well come he's a
high school thing why are we doing that
in college that's when app state beats
Michigan rock nice i'm coming that's
what I'm coming nice he went to f8 see
the welders are employed that was it
didn't work so well Scott this year by
the way rich didn't get him to stunt
well not all not all alumni you know can
come back every week and that's the one
week maybe they can come back see their
classmates their fraternity brothers all
down face first in a ditch wait what I'm
please help me how many games have you
been to since you graduated football yes
there none of them at the Dome I've been
like when Syracuse came here to LA to
play USC right go to that I was there as
well right but I have this job on
Sundays that sometimes conflicts right
so generally I have been to many of
those I've been to basketball games many
a basketball game but I have not been to
the carrier dome great football game
neither have I so it's been
12 years there James your jersey retired
yet my high school jersey is yes I was
College Jersey know via the 1,300 yards
I think I threw for you know I was
running quarterback I don't think that's
gonna get you your jersey retired
anytime soon all right Daniel Jeremiah
please they move the sticks podcast find
it NFL com where else well NFL com
itunes stitcher you can find all those
places Thanos remind the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience